welcome back to IBS is dueling townhall
with candidates Donald Trump and senator
Bernie Sanders who are answering
questions from the audience in turn keep
them down to 30 seconds gentleman this
next question comes to us from Jared
from Flint Michigan regarding health
care that thinks I'm uh I'm 25 going on
26 I'm unemployed with no prospects I
won't be able to be on my parents health
insurance anymore what can you do for me
okay frankly what I president I'm gonna
take care of everybody okay I am people
don't talk about okay no one's gonna be
dying in the streets I am so
compassionate no it talks about how
Quebec everyone who knows where they say
Donald just you're so compassionate you
are the compassionate machine I would
never call myself that that's what they
call the United States is the only
country without a nationalized health
care plan and we can do better okay um
how do you plan to pay courtland's
bigger government add more tax
yeah yeah okay I like call up carrot
works mean thanks there is a man who
need some hope next question comes from
Blake from Poughkeepsie New York who
says he's leaning toward mr. Trump but
is undecided regarding Bernie Sanders
his question is regarding job creation
thank you for taking my question with
workforce participation at a three
decade low how do you plan on increasing
the number of jobs available first we
need to ensure that every human making a
living wage China I will lose it
everywhere with China if everybody stays
with with free college okay yeah so we
both want to stick it to China is China
a part of TPP okay excuse me
the point is how do you plan on forcing
businesses to make the switch bigger
government add more tax a tariff moving
on this next question comes to us from
Stephanie from Mount Pleasant Michigan
Stephanie the floor is yours
thank you for taking my question with
the recent anti LGBTQA AIP laws passed
in places like North Carolina under the
guise of religious protection how can I
trust you to protect my right to use the
bathroom I walk okay nobody has more
friends
frankly that means okay and the LGBT can
be a AIP excuse me
okay whatever but we have a problem in
this country okay
we have people okay who want to go to
the ladies room frankly and do some
truthfully okay not very nice to the
worldís problem white people
okay why don't go into the ladies room
okay frankly and do these not nice ah no
men's room okay excuse me I thought you
wanted to I'm gender-fluid and there are
too many blacks getting gunned down in
the streets
I will fight from foe how do you like
that
more tariffs and the final question
comes to us from coach ripped from
Wichita Falls Texas who is a small
business owner as a small business owner
from from North Texas I'm interested in
knowing what you can do to make me
comfortable with voting for you okay
frankly great question okay beautiful
question I love that question the best
okay the best for you you're the future
we're asking the question is this guy
okay I am going to be frankly the best
for small businesses okay I am going to
be so good you're gonna love what I'm
gonna do all the programs are for small
businesses I don't believe the programs
excuse me okay
how's it feel with the Jews on the other
side you I said shoot but I don't want
to depress businesses are the backbone
of this country so
they don't make too much money and they
pay a $15 minimum wage yeah and you like
Chinese use their preferred bathrooms
have you buddy I don't want any
subsidies
okay frankly what do you want nothing
I'm not sure I want you the government
to do nothing excuse me we can't do
nothing okay cuz sometimes even nothing
okay is Franco something nothing I want
you to leave me alone and let me run my
business that's my right
trust truck okay that all of the
programs believe no programs zero
program is me okay you're very rude this
guy frankly you should at least hear the
program okay what is the program that
dice this
stay tuned for more townhall from IBS
news subscribe by clicking my face or
the button above me the one that says
subscribe if not you can watch some of
the videos next to me that are playing
in a box but I warn you at the end of
those videos there's another end card
with me encouraging you to subscribe but
instead you can also click the videos
and those videos too will have buttons
requesting that you subscribe so I could
choose your own path book like remember
goosebumps only you always end up
subscribing so just do it now and then
go watch the videos get it off your
plate